Four Seasons fast approaching and I
can't wait to talk about it you know the
season that sort of Blockbuster sequels
and a couple of other great shows that I
feel have gone under the radar this
year's fall season is going to be an
amazing one and for today I'll be
featuring my personal top 10 most
anticipated shows with sequels and new
anime on this list I know you'll find
something to really get excited about
[Music]
we start things off with a bang the hit
series Tokyo Avengers will have its
third season
foreign
given how big Tokyo Revengers turned out
to be it's no surprise that we'll be
getting a third season this October but
to finally have what people generally
consider the best arch adapted sign me
up it's about time for people who went
anime first to see the epicness that is
the tenjiku arc The tanjiku Arc is a
long one and when it's been hyped to be
the stage for Dorman's biggest battle
they're not kidding there's some good
Revelations and twists in this Arc and
this looks to be the arc that reignites
the fire for the Tokyo Avengers fandom
seeing as it's gone through a
comparative lull thanks to the previous
season's reception plus the whole thing
about some fans in less popular regions
being denied access to watching it
[Music]
thank you
let's feature a new show next Shangri-La
Frontier
here we have another Show featuring
video games but likely not the type
you'd expect I mean Shangri-La Frontier
Stars a gamer protagonist who's made it
his life goal to hunt terrible games
we're talking glitchy messes faulty
systems and features that are simply
from yesteryear yep it's his mission to
find all of those trash games and beat
all of them enter Shangri-La Frontier a
VR game that enters his crosses finally
setting his sights on a supposed god
tier Rocco Road looks to take the skills
he accrued from playing all those crappy
games and make his mark on this new
world shangreneur Frontier has been
getting quite a sizable audience
recently not enough to break into the
mainstream mind you but it's enough for
an anime adaptation Gamers especially
the more hardcore and devoted ones could
find something to like in this anime
[Music]
foreign
besides the next few entries on this
list this new game that I can't wait to
show you let's thank today's video
sponsor tails and Dragons New Journey
it's a really fun Idol RPG that anyone
can enjoy if you were to ask me however
the biggest thing tails and Dragons has
going for it has got to be the
characters and the world surrounding the
game the story takes place in the
Kingdom of Oz with the arrival of an
enigmatic witch and her spell the
draconic terror Shadow Tyrant gets
awakened the dragon unleashes
destruction like no other however though
all hope isn't lost as it falls to the
witch and the player character to stand
against the shadow Tyrant the battle to
restore the kingdom of Oz to its
previous form as a magical Paradise
begins and you'll be aided by a lot of
familiar faces these fairy tale
characters join the party and you can
quickly start your adventures with these
reliable allies and there's over a
thousand free draws upon logging to help
you out now what are you waiting for how
about checking out the link in the
description and getting into the action
or scam my QR code to get insane bonuses
by entering my Creator code tnd luck you
get 500 diamonds and more equivalent to
around thirty dollars so many rewards
await you as you enter this fairy tale
realm and I can't wait for you to join
the fun Venture into the fantasy slay
dragons with ease spy family is set to
make a return this fall too
[Music]
my family has become a Smash Hit almost
immediately can't say I didn't see it
come in either with its fun characters
ample amount of comedy and legitimately
wholesome and dramatic moments it's
easily carved its own niche in the
modern anime sphere as a chill show that
everyone can watch with their families
it carries a unique charm to it and the
fans can't wait to see more of the
lovable family in action thankfully this
fall season will be bringing the forgers
back we get to see the family back in
action and while we have a lot of laughs
and memories we'll also get more of them
in depth with some really immersive
storytelling people won't be as loud for
spy family as much as they'll be for the
big Shonen hits but it's always a
pleasure to have more of the series
animated
we go back to the realm of Gamers now
with Ragnar crimson
foreign
no I'm not talking about a game anime
this time instead of a world revolving
around video games Ragnar Crimson takes
us to a world familiar to anyone who
played a lot of the Legacy games from
the 90s we're talking the Medieval World
of dragons and dragon hunters and this
is where we get acquainted with the
Dragon Hunter ragna together with the
mysterious and unpredictable Crimson the
duo set forth on their goal to defeat
the dragon monarchs that have ruled the
world Ragnar Crimson is an anime that
ought to be a hit with people who
enjoyed a lot of RPGs from decades past
I hope it'll be a good adaptation
because the manga is seriously enjoyable
if you had fun with action adventure
series that deal with a lot of Monster
hunting and uneasy allegiances then
you'll have a blast with this one
[Music]
see nothing I
so
attached today
[Music]
as we approach the halfway mark we have
a shield Hero season three
what a roller coaster it's been for
shield hero the first season was a big
success such a smashing success that not
only did they announce the second season
back then but also a third one as well
as for the second season it had a
lukewarm reception nevertheless I'm
looking at season three as a chance for
the franchise to make a rebound perhaps
not to the highs of the first season but
to bring Shield hero a bit closer to His
Glory Days After all the spirit Turtle
Arc has been dealt with and we've got
better arcs coming there's also some
reshuffling of the staff so it seems
that they're going in on the attempt to
make their comeback season two did give
us some hooks on what to expect for the
third season the Revenge plot that
arguably carried the first season may
have been long dealt with but I'm sure
Shield hero will continue to have
something great for issakai fans
[Applause]
[Music]
enough of the sequels for now as we look
at Undead unlock for our next anime
and here's one of the shows I've been
excited about there's a lot I've said
about this show in the previous videos
and I'm very excited to watch this show
that puts a pair of death Seekers
together The Misfortune Laden fulco and
the immortal Andy make a very fun pair
to watch I'm positive you'll enjoy
watching the Antics as they try to work
for their goal of making the best
possible death for Andy all the while
attempting to thwart an organization in
the shadows that's taken an interest in
him Undead unlock could be the sleeper
hit amongst the niche anime of the
season I don't see this popping off and
becoming super mainstream but hey I've
been wrong a couple of times with these
kind of predictions entering a season
either way this should be a fun watch
for you if you're looking for a quirky
new show to enjoy
[Applause]
Dr Stone new Worlds part 2 is coming
this fall
ultrasounds continued meeting and
exceeding expectations with its
subsequent Seasons New World's no
different it's been a treat to watch the
first part so much that I just can't
wait for the continuation such as the
nature of these split cause at the cost
of turning some fans impatient to see a
more awesome anime it also builds up a
lot of anticipation and excitement plus
it allows the adaptation team to have a
break in order to continue creating more
anime with better quality either way
this thought should be a godsend to Dr
Stone fans with how new world has given
us yet another new and fresh take on the
long Adventures to uncover the mysteries
of the worldwide petrification fall and
the continuation of this new Journey
just can't come sooner Dr Stone has
never disappointed thus far and are more
than confident this part two will
continue that positive momentum
[Music]
is also scheduled to air in a few months
foreign
[Music]
ERS coming together to battle The Demon
King are all about the journey the quest
and the fight to get their goal but what
happens when the Demon King has been
defeated and the party disbands such as
the interesting premise the freyrene
looks to build on and deliver to us and
there's no better way to give us a
perspective than Through The Eyes of the
elf freyrent whose long life allows her
to outlive her Companions and give us a
substantial narration of the times with
her new companion Fern prieren embarks
on a brand new Journey visiting places
that bring back nostalgic Memories the
elf learns to confront her previous
regrets and builds on them with a new
story free rent Beyond Journey's End
looks to capture a similar Vibe and
atmosphere as to your eternity the way I
see it stories featuring long-lived
beings seeking to come to terms with
emotions and experiences where the
action is put to the Wayside in favor of
character drama be sure to check this
one out
[Music]
back on Titans finale is here
well
we got a banger of a movie special back
in March but the wait is over the final
chapters of the attack on Titan final
Arc is about to hit our screens is full
and anime fans all over the world just
can't wait it's a long time coming for
one of the best and most influential
anime the previous decade and after many
split cores that have turned into memes
the world is finally ready to lay
witness to the grand finale for real
this time long time fans will soon find
out how the hit series will end in anime
format while the manga has had a split
reception for its ending I'm really
holding out to see how the anime will
handle it on whether they build on it
and give us something better for the
anime viewers out there a grand farewell
to one of the biggest shows in the
Millennium one that helped put anime on
the map and there's no more deserving
show than Attack on Titan foreign
[Music]
lastly I want to divert your attention
to Pluto
foreign
Pluto topping this list now I'm pretty
sure that you haven't heard much about
this show and I don't blame you Pluto is
an old title but it was also one of the
best sci-fi Thrillers back then building
off the genius of dezukar's works on
robots and AI it shifts the focus onto
the Astro Boy supporting character
jessic in order to give us a dark tail
on one of the exceptional arcs in the
legendary series is a story of mysteries
and conspiracy as jessic takes it upon
himself to investigate a famed robot's
tragic demise to which he gets forced
into a race of time in order to protect
the fragile balance that characterizes
the coexistence of man and machine for
sci-fi aficionados this is a new anime
that I just can't recommend enough
foreign
and if you found a show that you're
super excited about this for then don't
forget to leave it down in the comment
section and share your thoughts fall
2023 is looking to be a great season and
I'd love to know your thoughts on it as
well as the shows you're excited about
that I didn't feature on the list don't
forget to check out tales and Dragons
links in the description thanks for
watching and I hope you have a great day